this is a production of Cornell
University
and we'll start with yesterday was the
dead and it was such a a big hit Carl
that I just couldn't resist having two
days in a row of bonus content and since
we're talking baseball today with Evan
machete I think we should say goodbye to
Holyfield uh one of the oldest uh same
location baseball fields in the NCAA uh
established in 1922 and I believe the
last game uh has in fact been played on
this Carl uh and I think the first game
this weekend is being played on the new
uh boothfield complex that's moved off
campus a little bit and Evan take a good
look because we're going to talk about
synthetic Fields uh as well because I
want to see you go down the rabbit hole
on getting these surfaces uh to behave
in a particular way Carl so we're good
to go I can move right into it we'll do
the we'll do the way we've been doing it
I'll get going and then pass to you
perfect perfect perfect okay so uh
everybody welcome to the show this is
the sports edition the Yanks are winning
the Red Sox are losing it's a good day
the universe is aligned and and while we
make our way through the fastest 30
minutes it's it's good to just remind
everybody you know everybody should be a
Yankee fan Evan I thought I'd start out
with a couple of goofy first picture
gifts right who can resist I don't even
know who did this but is hysterical you
throw it and hit the guy in the camera
right in the soft spot right but this is
the best one the dog first pitch the
Bulldog running in from uh home plate
with the ball on his back works every
time velcroed on his back so we're in
for a fun chat here about baseball today
but as we're talking about growing grass
even though it isn't the primary focus
many times of baseball fields it's been
warm everybody knew it was above normal
as much as 20 degrees above normal last
week and it looks like it's going to be
a quick return to normal so it's
probably going to feel colder as average
temperatures particularly in the upstate
New York area are going to go back into
the 40s and at night maybe into the 30s
so we're still going to be a few degrees
above normal but nowhere near uh what we
were now looking across the region we're
about 10 to 21 days using Growing Degree
Days and the way heat accumulates since
March 15th is the value we use we're
about 10 to 21 days ahead of normal I
don't feel that I think this is one of
those places where Degree Days might be
a little bit off I like soil temperature
better and we're going to talk about
that in a minute now speaking of soils
they're dry yeah last week everybody was
less than a quarter inch through the
region uh we got some rain coming almost
everybody's going to get some rain
through the weekend there certainly was
a patch of wet weather in in
Northwestern New Jersey uh but not a lot
of people we talked to have actually
seen that but there's much as a a three
four inch dump that happened there where
most of the rest of the region was less
than a quarter of an inch so should be
about an inch coming through at least
Upstate New York uh and the Metro region
uh on Sunday Sunday should be a washout
which could be a big loss when a lot of
people use in fields on the weekend now
this is something worth noting and also
when you're taking care of dirt no
matter where it is you know the overall
pattern is we've been dry for almost a
month month now and there's a big strong
gradient out in Buffalo Rochester pretty
wet you come through the central region
and all the way down to the southeast
where it gets really dry in fact the new
drought map is up uh yesterday so I
included it here and you're starting to
see some real uh dryness moderate
drought starting to occur all the way
from you know Maryland and Delaware West
Virginia maybe probably in Northern
Virginia all the way up to Rhode Island
up the I-95 Corridor a pretty pretty
accumulated dry weather which is good
you know if you're getting out and it's
dry it's good but if you're managing
these fields having to irrigate fields
to keep them growing to get the traffic
tolerance isn't always something that's
easy to do now when you look at soil
temperatures they're really starting to
warm up everybody's really in the 50s I
mean if you're watching us here you can
see we got some blue colors but even the
blues there's only a few places where
it's still in the 30s but those are the
highest elevations in along some of the
lakefront areas for sure now soil
temperature is going to drive weeds
Weeds on Spore fields are quite a
problem lesser celandine is the one that
everybody's talking about right now this
is a perennial that comes and goes if it
is a perennial problem for you there are
options for controlling it but literally
after it flowers and it sort of
vegetates you can't see it anymore so if
it's a chronic problem you have to
wonder about uh other things you're
doing in your management program that
might be uh leaving this especially on a
sports field even avoid now flat weeds
the winter annuals uh and perennial
early perennials are flowering and
that's starting to happen now across the
region so everybody across the region
should be seeing something in flower uh
right now if it's growing in the lawn
and it's able to flower at a low mowing
height we're just starting to touch into
where the Ester formulation of 240 works
really well on Broad leaves in the
spring up the Hudson Valley and in the
Met Metro New York New Jersey area
Philly Harrisburg stuff like that so
you're starting to get into that zone so
that means the dandelions probably
getting blooming now so these sorts of
recommendations actually look uh pretty
consistent with uh where we're seeing
we're seeing almost no maybe one or two
dandelions beginning to bloom here in
upstate Central New York crabgrass just
maybe early Germans you know along
buildings where things are really hot
bare areas tend to get some germination
again with the wear and tear Fields take
particularly in the fall that was pretty
dry uh that the winter fixed a little
bit uh we went in pretty dry
um having thin Turf poor Turf getting
going in the spring you're probably
going to get crabgrass and not we
germinating before you get any Turf
grasses germinating so if you want to
get out there and get rye grass going I
would definitely encourage you to start
doing that you've got those feels being
used uh all by all means start to get
into that repetitive overseas eating
soils are warm enough that rye grass
will get going and you know remember the
old saying I think it was a USDA
agronomist so God Rest his soul Stan
zontec used to say rye grass is better
than no grass now a lot of times people
have these kinds of fields during the
season and they got crabgrass all over
the place right and so you got bare
areas if you don't have broad leaves you
might have crab grass and so you have
options now at seeding right in the past
it used to be just two percent and so
now if you have the ability to use
herbicides and you've got to do some
seeding you can incorporate tenacity in
there and mesotrione will also give you
a little annual Bluegrass we'll give you
some post-emergent crabgrass control so
there's a lot of options here in sports
Fields where you want to over seed and
also manage the weed control
particularly if you're behind the eight
ball already this spring right if you're
coming out in the fall coming out of the
Fall thin and you're starting to Spring
thin you know it was a mild winter maybe
kids were out there even playing through
the the winner depending on where you
were in the Northeast there wasn't
enough snow to keep them off and not
everybody you know can get those kids
trained on sneakers like Ben Palmer can
right so you might have some wear and
tear you might need some herbicides I'd
start with the overseeding and then go
to the herbicides and here is the man of
the hour I found out a geologist who
actually wanted to wound up being a
sports field guy and now turning out
back to geology along the way Evan
welcome before we talk about the dirt
we're going to have Carl talk but before
we have Carl talk a little bit about his
Spiel he's got a great one coming for me
I want to talk about what you did here I
think if was this your Masters I don't
know when you did this work this was
advising sod producers on how to manage
sod in the field
so that when you thick cut it and put it
down it had Maximum Traction
yeah maximum maximum divot resistance
Max some different resistance right
which means you know you're you're
getting better traction right you're
resisting a divot right yes
so so what I thought was cool here and
you know we folks can read this in this
old Sports they're old now right we're
old men now years ago right and and the
interesting thing was low nitrogen low
nitrogen production areas that actually
weren't that green had better divot
resistance than higher end better
looking grass can you talk for a second
about how you did this and what you
found
sure you're correct this was my Master's
project we worked with a sod farm to
look at some of their management
practices and you know at the high level
where these NFL or high-level College
Fields are resotted all the time the
field manager doesn't have much time to
really adjust the condition of the turf
uh because you're shotting and then
playing on it only a few days later so
there's really no time for the sod to
root or cutting it pretty thick you know
an inch and three quarters two inches of
of root zone so to speak and so it has
to be stable right away and so the
management factors that go on the facade
Farm is really what governs how the fuel
will perform once it gets to the stadium
and one of the obviously the most basic
cultural practices that we use in turf
management is fertilizer and this is
especially true when you're in an
establishment scenario like sod so the
production timeline for this kind of
side is usually around 14 months it
would be seated like in August or you
know late summer early fall of kind of
year one and then it'll be harvested
around Thanksgiving of year two
and so we were looking at you know once
the turf is established and you've
gotten it to grow in
what can we do to to maximize the root
growth and the amount of rhizomes that
facade is you know best knitted and we
found that there's a sort of trade-off
between visual visual quality so to
speak on top and the the performance of
the the root Zone the stabilization by
those roots and rhizomes and it really
it comes down to just what what the
grass plan is trying to do you know when
you fertilize obviously it's going to
take advantage of that nutrient because
nitrogen is pretty scarce in nature and
it's going to grab on and try to produce
as much vertical top growth as possible
and that the consequences that is it
uses up all the sugars that that can be
produced through photosynthesis and
instead as as football field managers
we'd rather those sugars go into storage
in the crowns or or even better into
roots and rhizomes and so that was kind
of what we found was that by sacrificing
a little bit of color you know you can
make up for this with dye and pigments
and other things but you could actually
get the feel to play better
real quick well done Evan thanks for
that and for all of you that's the end
of the grass conversation for today
because it's infield dirt day and just
in case anybody didn't know this if you
worked I grabbed this off of one of your
presentations Evan thanks for making
this slide I got to put the credit thing
at the bottom here the labor intensity
uh in a baseball field you look at how
little uh the dirt area makes up in a
field uh maybe 15 but it takes eighty
percent ninety percent of the resources
to tend to it so I asked chat gbt Carl
what about this film mix right I asked
for I asked the the machine what makes
the best mix and it says depends on
climate and soil in the area the amount
of sand silt and Clay it can vary Carl
which I know you're gonna get right into
now and it's also important about the
maintenance so you know I'd encourage
someone to just type in what's the best
mix for baseball infields the machines
pretty good here Carl so the pressure's
on bro brother what do you got what do
you got for us today
yeah so it's great to see that slide the
infield stuff Frank and I'm going to get
to that the the sort of effort and and
the Precision that you put into getting
excellence and when we're going to talk
about really sort of Highly managed in
fields today MLB level uh high level
NCAA and and I got to thinking you know
Excellence when people think of that at
that highest level they think of the
effort you put in on the turf side it's
the timing of products we talked all day
yesterday with Rich about timing
applications for root diseases it's uh
the product selection it's the
deployment of Labor uh and so I got to
thinking of John wrong just won the
Masters right he's one of the best
players in in all of golf and obviously
execution's a big part of that but what
all these great players do and and what
great operations do is they build in
this margin of error for themselves so
that they concede and this they can
succeed in this wider sort of array of
situations uh and when you look at
someone like John Rahm a golfer and you
look at his swing uh we'll look at a
swing here and everybody go to golf
lesson real quick uh you can see things
in his swing that build in margin for
error so I've got three pictures for
those uh who aren't watching there's a
picture of him pre-impact at impact and
post impact and the things that that
golf instruction instructors will remark
on is his Club face stays very uh sort
of square to the Target it's not
rotating a bunch through impact uh he's
not using his hands his little muscles
to really sort of square it up with
timing he's using a lot of body rotation
his bigger muscles uh to clear through
and control that plug face and what that
does is it builds in margin for error
right he doesn't have to rely on that
timing that can vary shot to shot those
smaller muscles he's using bigger
muscles that's what allows him to hit a
lot of good shots and then to do it
under pressure like you know 18th hole
at Augusta so he bill building this
margin for error in his golf swing and
then when you start to look at maybe
some sports metaphors uh right back when
we were able to shift the idea behind
analytics and shifts was that hey you
know instead of relying on a shortstop
who's got to cover a lot of ground over
there if the ball gets hit in that
direction hey if we know a player is
going to hit it over that side of the
infield a lot of time let me just put
three people over there instead of two
and that lowers our need to execute at
this really high level and it builds in
that margin for error so that's the idea
behind analytics and then you start
getting into turf management and these
things that we do that increase margin
of error so things like removing trees
around putting greens right that gives
us more light it gives us more air
that's going to produce better grass and
a larger array of environments soil
specifications right USGA putting green
specifications that helps us control
moisture even when we're getting a lot
of it we're not getting a whole lot
right now up here but when you do that
gives you more margin for error you can
still produce good greens when you're
getting a whole lot of rain same thing
with Athletic Field drainage right
better in more situations this is where
we transition into your work Evan uh
with within field mixes right and trying
to figure out hey what's that range I
can keep of soil moisture in the infield
dirt that gives me the you call it
cleaning cleaned out sort of the nice
performance of that infield and you've
got a really cool graphic over there
right you know historically we've got
this really small range if we're too dry
I've got a picture up here of the the
sort of the clotting I think you call it
the clumping that happens when you get
too dry you get these chunks all over
the baseball then when it's when it's
taking a hot may go a weird direction
and you know hit someone's chin or you
know cause an error or something so you
got to keep it dry wet enough to avoid
that and then also if you get too wet
right you get the slippage and sort of
the instability that you don't like so
uh we can get to this final side here
and I don't explain too much of it Evan
and this is where I'll bring you in but
uh you know I talked about USGA
specifications and really what you're
looking at now is specifying these
infield mixes using sort of traditional
geology these engineering Concepts and
what you're saying is hey you know we
might have 20 percent and say a 20 clay
in a mix but it actually matters what
kind of play you have to get those sort
of soil moisture ideal soil moisture
bands again for the people who aren't
watching there's these three different
play types they're present in the same
percentages when you test them in the
lab but certain ones have larger sort of
moisture ranges so that's the way we're
bringing in Evan so what led you to
start investigating this and how have
you applied those sort of Geo geology
principles uh into this uh you know
specification uh business you're in now
I'll just say you guys have remarkable
comprehension uh you've Cherry Picked
all the best slides and and I'm very
impressed at your ability to to
reiterate the important Concepts here so
I got interested in this topic while I
was working after I did that sod project
I left and worked at various
professional baseball stadiums around
the country mostly on the eastern half
the United States but I just found it
really interesting that um depending on
where you go the soil would perform
really differently even when this the
particle size analysis would come out
very similar you could have that like
Chad GPT recommended you could pretty
much follow their recommendations but
you might not get the same result and uh
so people have tried this with different
kinds of Clays and we picked these three
because they're
um they're sort of the most common
families of clay minerals they're
different sort of subspecies so to speak
within minerals just like there is
within the kingdom of life
but these are the sort of most common
minerals that are found in nature
depending on the uh the climate and the
parent material that rocks basically
that are allowed to form the different
clays
and they have different structures and
and we don't have to get into the the
nitty-gritty of that but essentially
what what makes it the biggest
difference is the Affinity of the clay
surface for water right so smack tight
in particular it's a two to one plate
has a lot more surface area and it has a
lot of charge so there's a lot of
negative charge associated with the
surfaces and those surfaces are they're
hungry for water they want to be
satisfied and as a result they can
actually grab onto or retain a lot more
water and maintain their stiffness
compared to something like like a
one-to-one clay like a kaolinite which
is a lot more broken down doesn't have
quite as much surface area and uh shape
a little bit differently and so you know
this is a the scrap or this this series
of charts is a little bit
it's a little bit difficult to interpret
not having the background of a whole
experiment but essentially the length of
the bar would represent the acceptable
range of water content where you could
actually play on that infield yeah and I
got this one right yeah yeah here's
another same thing yeah this is the
version of the same thing that has them
has them across it and it's just the 60
20 20. right and Carl's point the margin
of Errors The Wider the bar
it means the what it'll perform in that
wide range of moisture content is that
that that's what this is saying that's
right that's right with properties of
clay that use the gun to identify okay
look listen we've been on a few times we
this is I think the third time we've I
think it might be the third yeah I think
the third time one time we talked about
that scientist that created that little
vessel that you tested something we're
not going down that rabbit hole but but
you know for people to understand now if
they're managing Clays that to get to
Carl's wonderful point about the margin
for error right
um there are different Clays that get
used in these systems and you noticed it
early on when you were working with like
wait a minute it's the same 60 20 20 but
it behaves totally differently you've
identified these things can a guy go out
Evan and just buy this stuff and say
listen I want a 60 20 20 kaola night
sesqui oxide mix clay can I do that now
no unfortunately not we're not to play
to that level maybe maybe the future
that will be possible um for one thing
companies that that are you know mining
and Excavating and blending these
materials some of them are aware of this
but a lot of them aren't that you know
to them you know it's red dirt and brown
dirt they're not really aware of the
claim of Neurology
um and secondly it's you know it's
geographically dependent so no
unfortunately we're not quite to that
that phase yet okay so listen one of the
things you talked about I want to expand
the conversation and get you to
speculate a little bit in the last 10
minutes things you might actually not
know but probably no more than you think
you do uh until somebody asks you the
question so here's the question
we got a lot of crappy weather up here
uh in in Upstate New York and you know
Cornell's been playing baseball
literally since February
um a lot of people particularly without
snow this year you know it was cold uh
and dry which might not be bad but
you've talked a lot about how these
things these Clays behave with the
moisture can you speculate a little bit
on how these Clays behave under cooler
and wider ranges of temperatures
uh I don't I don't think the mineralogy
plays such a role so much as as the way
the water is able to flow through the
surface so I mean the higher certainly
the the higher swelling Clays they're
going to be more affected by freezing
and thawing because they have more water
associated with them over the winter
time so that you know that could be more
of a concern where you can get more
heaving
um but as far as like the temperature
itself once this once the soil is thawed
out I don't think really would interact
necessarily with the mineralogy
so the mineralogy but what about working
it oh oh definitely I mean the
workability there's almost like when
this okay so let's go back let's go back
for a second you did say something
swelling Clays which one of these is a
swelling clay that's smack tight on the
bottom that's an expansive clay so
depending on the the type of cations
that are in there whether it's sodium or
calcium this is more of an issue out
west where in the East Eastern half the
United States where precipitation
exceeds E.T you're more likely to find a
calcium sectite Which is less expansive
but will still undergo a lot quite a bit
of shrinking swelling and that will
crack as it dries out okay so let me go
back to the slide that we that Carl put
up here because
um the smell this is seems odd to me the
smackdite performed better over a wider
range so did well all the Clays perform
better over a wider range when there was
less of it in the mix
yeah this is a little bit it's a little
bit goofy
um and one thing that's not captured
here so like the Left End of the bar
this represents that cleat and clean out
water content and once you get above
when you get to these higher sand
contents although they can still perform
and give you that that cleat and clean
out performance it's never going to act
the same as a mix with like 60 or 55
sand so as you approach the point where
the sand grains start to stack against
one another and Bridge and form that
rigid skeleton
um you give up some of that playability
and so although it is easier to manage
uh from a water standpoint if you were
to put professional athletes on these
sandier mixes you'd have a very
difficult time maintaining that
um
I don't want to leave Clays completely
but
this other than temperature let's get
back to working plays when the
temperatures are cooler and assuming not
covered which is the majority of Youth
and up you know the high school baseball
fields
give me a one-on-one on this so number
one is if you're well if you're trying
to walk or drive equipment on the field
and it's rutting or it's making
Footprints you need the only thing that
you can do is stay off until it dries
out enough it's so tempting no matter
how skilled you are or how long you've
been doing this everybody wants to get
out there and do something because we
all feel like we need to be doing
something right so the number one thing
is is to wait and the reason is you're
going to destroy whatever stability is
already there and by walking or driving
in that field you're actually creating
positive water pressure in the pores and
that the you know that pressure is
basically going to blow the cert the
soil apart and it's going to make it
even harder to get back into shape so
that's number one
hold on let me reiterate number one
if you get any kind of surfaces smearing
as you described here the technical term
of smearing right uh right
um you're not only injuring that surface
for that moment but that potentially has
lasting impacts on your ability to
recover it it does if you have any
conditioner on the surface you're very
liable to bury that because you're
incorporating it you know probably too
deeply into the skin yeah you're going
to create large Footprints or ruts that
are going to be difficult to repair so
absolutely not just for today but for
the future you know stay off that field
until you can get out there without
running it okay
um conditioner you brought up
should I put conditioner on in the fall
uh or should I make sure it is nothing I
mean generally the conditioner goes on
and comes off you don't really want to
leave conditioner on there do you right
yeah I I would always take the
conditioner off in the fall if you have
the ability to do that
um you can sweep it you can get into a
pile of The Backpack Blower if you want
to leave it there you know to save
yourself a step I mean that's okay but I
like to take it off because it it blows
into the turf right so over the over the
winter time we're worried about not just
water erosion but also the wind erosion
and uh that can create some issues with
build up especially along the back Arc
so typically you know you take this
strip the conditioner in the fall and
then reapply in the spring and you don't
want to incorporate the conditioner into
the infield mix correct no that's
correct there's an older you know in
older days the mentality was to actually
put this material in and till it in you
know as a soil a soil conditioner so to
say no but we've kind of gotten away
from that philosophy
um although those materials will absorb
more water and that's not to say they're
not going to help you get out there
after rain events you're really you're
losing a lot of benefit because you want
that material right at the surface
through the absorption if you know those
conditioner particles are two or three
inches down they're not really helping
you that much and they're going to
reduce the stability and make it more of
a Sandbox you know consistency
for your buck is keeping it at the
surface that's right and and the
conditioner has the you know during the
season has the benefit of actually
holding moisture uh in in the clay uh
not it's not itself being moist but sort
of covering the infield clay so it can't
lose as much right it acts like a little
bit of a buffer
um there's kind of there's different
viewpoints on that and there's there's
two different you know there's the main
different kinds of conditioner there's
the vitrified or expanded Shale type
versus the calcine clay the calcine clay
does have a pretty high affinity for
water and so in some cases it can
actually steal the moisture from the
underlying infield mix but in general if
that conditioner is kept moist you had
acts kind of like a mulch or like a
blanket to insulate from the Sun
okay folks we have officially gone down
the rabbit hole if you thought smectite
was the beginning of the rabbit hole we
we are there now Evan so
I gotta not damage it first so it's
first Do no harm what's the next thing
to get these feels going in the spring
when it's cooler than maybe you'd like
yeah then the next thing is to get a
good roll in that field because no
matter what clay type you have you're
going to have some at least in these
this Northern climate you're going to
have some freezing and thawing
associated with the wintertime uh cold
temperatures so getting ideally you can
get a one or a three ton roller or
something you can rent you know dual
drum smooth drum that you can get a nice
roll to get that Frost heave out if you
don't have access to something like that
you can tire roll or you can use a
roller that just you know fills with
water and the drum that you can tow
behind but that's that's kind of the
next step and then if you've got any any
small leveling to do I mean this would
be a good time to do that also um
it's generally doing a full till laser
grade in the springtime is challenging
because there's oftentimes some wet
spots and it's difficult to get
everything repacked but that's the
reality that oftentimes we have to do
that that's When contractors can fit Us
in right and uh so if there's any major
leveling that needs to be done obviously
we didn't really talk much about that
but the best way to prevent you know
rainouts is having that positive surface
grade and avoiding your bird baths yeah
all right listen I don't want to get the
synthetic I want you to tell me about
the key test for those who've uh uh I
didn't put it on here Evan has a website
with much of his work including a link
to the recording we did last year
um and Evan I'm going to talk about the
key test I'm not going to show the video
of you developing this tool to
demonstrate the cleat end pleat out and
the clotting uh I'd refer people to the
website for that and also this really
cool Tool uh app you built where you can
move the very there's bars along and
determine water content this is a really
cool little thing uh Evan well done but
let's start with the key test uh what is
the key test that you so you called it
canonical
yes this is one of the first things you
learn when you're taking care of the
Enfield to judge you know subjectively
how is the moisture how is the
uniformity of the moisture as a function
of depth and uh you know do we need to
be adding water onto the surface this is
after a game you can see on the left
side there's actually a little bit of a
you know bulge or a shoves and then some
flea marks and this played really well
because you can actually get that key
you know everybody's everybody that
works in facility management has these
big brass do not duplicates you can jam
one of these into the ground without too
much resistance and it becomes just
something you learn by feel you know how
much force does it take to get this key
in there and then does it come out
cleanly and so ideally this key would
come out without any soil being removed
without anything sticking it's almost
like baking you know cupcakes where you
put the toothpick in and see yeah but
that that wasn't good enough for you
that wasn't good enough for you no so
that's you know that that test is a
little bit subjective and it doesn't
really give us any data points about how
much water is actually in there so we
built this machine at Penn State with
the help of the Engineering Services
shop to actually replicate athletes
running around in these soil samples and
this prevents us from having to use
human subjects we can do this in the lab
where I'm located right now and we can
just build these soil samples that are
about the size of a coffee can roughly
and then we control the moisture and
then we actually test them to figure out
what is that critical water content
where the soil will begin to chunk out
as opposed to giving us that Cleveland
outperformance
the engineering guys must love you so
what about this little Gadget what about
this little tool of moving the different
particle size things
um this this looks like it's going to
have application uh in the future if we
can have access to these kinds of mixes
right I think so I mean this is
something I just built kind of for fun
um but if you're a soil supplier and
your goal is to produce you know a
infield mixture with 60 sand but you are
doing this by mixing a sandy soil and a
clay soil well in nature there's no such
thing usually as pure sand or pure clay
so it's not just a matter of adding well
six parts of the sand and four parts of
the clay
you have to account for the fact that
the sandy soil has some fines in it and
the clay soil has some sand in it
usually even clay soils would have
between you know five and thirty or even
40 sand if it's a like a loamy texture
yeah you almost have to have 20 clay
to have Clay in the name using that
that's right if you look at that
textural triangle the the clay bearing
soils they dominate most of that and
doesn't take very much clay to affect
the behavior of the soil and that's kind
of what that triangle is getting at so
this is just a it's a simple you know
toy calculator if you had no if you know
the particle size analysis of the
fine-grained soil or the clay soil and
also the sandy soil this will give you
the ratio in order to achieve that file
mixture of 60 or 70 sand everybody's
going to remember when you were on this
goofy show with us when you become the
next Norm Hummel this you're plowing
absolutely new ground here Evan
that's right little soil fun there okay
listen Before I Let You Go uh what are
your thoughts about these synthetic
surfaces right most people I actually
think Carl we don't have a clay Mound I
think the new field has a synthetic
Mound okay it's not a whole damn thing
synthetic what do you think and this is
I think a very practical matter in where
we play baseball in the winter time up
here
um did do you have any insights into how
these surfaces behave are they really
favorable because they're pretty uniform
and do you know anything about the
Rubber and the way that stuff behaves or
if you just stay down the dirt hole
so in my PhD I haven't gone down this
this particular hole but we did we've
done some studies in the past at the
center for sports surface research here
with my advisor Andy mcnet and uh Tom
Sorensen's the manager of our research
program we've done some studies on
different uh different blends of infill
oftentimes these have a mixture of sand
and rubber or now they're going to more
like organic cork or coconut choir type
and fill materials so I don't have a ton
of personal experience with it but the
companies that manufacture these
products have gotten pretty good and the
playability is much better than it used
to be to the point where the bounces are
much more uniform it used to be the
players really would complain about the
the elasticity of the rubber and I think
depending on the system that those
concerns have been alleviated somewhat
the the mound and the plate are a real
concern as are the lead off areas and
like most Synthetic Turf
um are all Synthetic Turf obviously
these are they're not no maintenance you
know certainly there's going to be less
dragging less obviously there's no
mowing so the maintenance is less but um
you really need to pay attention to
these high traffic areas and
periodically the mound the home plate
and even those like I said the leadoff
areas those have to get lifted and
replaced and um they can be pretty
routinely pretty pretty routinely like
pretty often and that can be expensive
so it's something to be aware of you
know if you're thinking of installing a
feel like this you do it obviously you
can get out there sooner in the
springtime there's going to be some
unforeseen headaches associated with
those high traffic areas yeah and you've
got to literally go out we
you got to go out ever after every game
just like they go out and fix in the
clay after a game you got to go out and
sprinkle a little rubber and move that
around because the more you leave those
fibers exposed uh your advisor Andy
mcnit has taught us uh the quicker they
break down the more they abrade and the
life expectancy of the field uh the
client so it's almost like those areas
need to be peeled out I think they've
got them with velcro or glue or
something that they can be peeled out
all right listen Carl
it wasn't the fastest 30 minutes it was
34 minutes with bonus content Evan thank
you uh for taking the time uh to join us
Carl I are there any pressing questions
uh or I want to get out of here I I
think we're just downloading our
Material Science uh half an hour for the
day it's it's really cool to hear the
specification stuff and like you're
saying Frank maybe hey we're gonna have
these uh more refined specifications for
infields I'm thinking about putting
greens and the angles of Sands right the
angularity and stuff so uh it's really
cool to you know another pun get in the
dirt and talk about some of those
details so thanks a bunch after machete
uh we've got his uh website down there
and all the links so if you're watching
on YouTube you can go check out that
website thanks everybody for joining
episode uh 10 of the church show this
year uh we'll see you next uh next week
thanks Carl thanks Evan good to see you
thanks guys well done
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu